[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLEN DOWD: We're
going to talk today
about building blocks
around digital and IoT
for manufacturing.
It's a topic that is super
near and dear to our heart,
as Hitachi.
We are a manufacturer.
That's what we do.
It's in our core DNA.
We also have
consulting companies
and technology companies
and health care companies
and a bunch of other things.
But when it comes down to it,
at our core, for 108 years
since we were founded, we've
been doing manufacturing.
We have 145,000
manufacturing employees
across almost 200
factories that exist
in 21 different countries.
So when we talk about, as
we're going through this today,
we talk about the challenges
that are facing manufacturers.
We talk about the challenges
that are facing, really,
all of us that work in
the industrial space.
We're living it every day.
We're trying to
modernize our own plants.
Were trying to modernize
our own operations.
We're trying to
connect our supply
chains in different ways.
We have the same challenges
that you guys, the manufacturers
in the room, are facing.
So, hopefully, we can
kind of power through it
together in the conversation
and have some good discussion.
So we are going to do
our very best to leave
time at the end for questions.
If you guys come
up with questions,
there are microphones
around the room.
I've been warned that my
co-presenter, the wonderful Mr.
Rob Lively, who's going to
come up and talk technology
for a bit, goes a
little bit long.
So it's possible we may not
have time for questions,
but we're going to do our best.
So I just realized, rude me,
I have not introduced myself.
My name is Ellen Dowd.
I'm a senior vice
president with Hitachi.
I'm responsible for
our digital solution
portfolio for the social
innovation business.
So you saw the video that
talks about our story
around social innovation, but
for all intents and purposes,
we believe that by changing
business, you change the world.
And that's essentially
what we're talking about
as we go through this.
So let's talk about
this crazy world.
It is pretty insane right now.
There's only really
one way to describe
it, which is massive change,
massive transformation.
We're all going through it.
It's everything from
the fact that the world
is shrinking-- we've got
globalization pressures that
are happening.
We have generational shifts.
We have all of these
trends that are happening.
And what that's causing
is a shift of power
and a shift of sort of dominance
in the business market.
So if you think about the
Fortune 500, for the first,
I don't know, eight decades
that the Fortune 500 existed,
that list was almost
entirely static.
The same companies were
on it year after year,
to the point where if a
company fell off of the list,
it was news.
We talked about it.
Over the course of the last
15 years, 52%, more than half,
of the Fortune 500s
dropped off the list.
That is a staggering number,
and it's particularly
scary to the manufacturers.
Because for the majority
of the 20th century,
that's who dominated that list.
Yeah, there were
a few retailers,
some energy companies, some
financial services companies.
But for the most part,
it was the manufacturers
that were dominating that list.
So we are seeing pressures,
as manufacturers,
as industrial companies,
coming from every direction
that you can imagine.
How we respond to that is going
to dictate how we actually
survive in this new economy.
So you can't talk about digital
without the word disruptor
coming reasonably close
in the same sentence.
It follows pretty
closely after digital.
But I'm going to
argue that what we
talk about as disruptors aren't
actually disruptors anymore.
We've moved well beyond
the disruption phase.
We're now officially
to the point
where these are just the
facts of our business.
This is how we exist,
how we survive,
how we're actually
getting through, working
with the competition,
reaching our customers.
Generational shifts are there.
Pervasive connectivity.
Everything is connected.
Our devices are connected.
We're doing competing
at the edge.
We've got 5G that's
coming out and is
going to be widely adopted
within the next three years.
Connectivity is at a rate
that we've never seen before.
And the maturing technologies
are becoming mainstream.
IA, machine learning,
blockchain--
these aren't new
concepts anymore.
They're mainstream technologies.
So we need to start
thinking about not
so much about digital
disruptors and more
about digital enablers.
How are we enabling
our business?
OK, so here is the good news.
This is, I think, where
the opportunity really is.
So if you look at the numbers--
so, a couple of things.
I'm a consultant.
I've been a consultant my entire
life until the last few years.
And, as a consultant, I
really like statistics,
so you guys are going to have to
bear with me just a little bit.
I'm going to rattle
a whole bunch off.
But there's a point here,
and they're actually
pretty interesting.
So let's start with
the fact that Gartner
did a survey, talked to 1,500
executives that were out there,
and asked them this question.
And before I give you the answer
to how many of them said this,
I'm going to-- again,
audience participation.
Bear with me.
I'm going to ask
this group of people.
Who in this room
believes the digital
is a critical
competitive advantage,
or will be a critical
for your company?
About the same.
So 81% of those
participants responded
that they believed this was a
critical piece of their agenda.
It was going to be a
differentiator for them
going forward.
Second question.
Bear with me, guys.
Come on.
You guys don't seem really
excited about the hand raising,
but I'm almost done, I promise.
So second question.
How many of you
think you're seeing
the results that you
should be seeing yet
from digital initiatives?
Really small number.
Same thing happened
there, 24% said
they were seeing the results.
So how is it that everybody
believes it's a priority?
The executives believe it's
going to be a differentiator.
But nobody's seeing the results.
It's a really, really
interesting thing.
Oh, sorry, guys.
It becomes more interesting
when you think about the why.
My knee-jerk reaction
when I hear that
is, oh, well, they're
just not investing enough.
They're not putting enough
money into these programs.
They need to spend
more on digital.
Then they'll see more results.
Turns out, that's not
the answer, either.
You look at what HBR,
Harvard Business Review,
has actually figured
out, if you look
at digital leaders, the
top 25% of adopters,
and digital laggards, the
bottom 25% of adopters,
they are spending almost the
same exact amount of money
on IT.
As a percentage of revenue,
it's almost exactly the same.
It goes from 3.2% to 3.5%.
That's the gap.
It's tiny.
It's almost negligible.
But if you look at the gap
in terms of their business
performance, it's amazing.
80% improvement on
operating income.
57% increase on profit line.
So those are huge
results without a lot
of incremental spend.
That's a huge opportunity.
Sorry, guys, I'm
a little parched.
I think I'm drinking water
out of a milk carton,
is what it looks like.
So this begs the
question, and this
is really the important
thing, how are they doing it?
If they're able to not
spend that much more money
and yet achieve these
fantastic results,
what are they doing differently
than the rest of us?
What are they doing differently
than their competitors?
So this is what I
think we're going
to spend the rest of
the time talking about.
Setting the stage
with statistics
and what the industry is
doing and all the pressures
that we're having
is interesting,
but I think we all are
interested in understanding how
do we achieve these results.
How do we approach these
problems in different ways,
tackle them in
different ways, so
that we can start seeing some
of those massive benefits that
are available to us if
we do things a little bit
differently.
So let's talk
about what we think
are the top four things
that you should be thinking
about doing differently.
You should be thinking
about changing your mindset.
So the first thing is-- and
it sounds really simple,
but it's actually probably the
hardest part of all of this.
Envision the actual
business change that you're
trying to accomplish.
What do you want to be when
you grow up as a company?
What do you want to
be in your industry?
How are you going to change the
way that you're doing business?
So this could be anything from
moving from being a product
company to a services
company, changing
the way you think
about R&D. Maybe
it's not product R&D anymore.
Maybe you're looking
at innovation,
how to build true
innovation programs inside
of your company.
How do you actually
change the way
that you're thinking
about your business
so that you can design
technology to help
you achieve that change?
OK, so this is everybody's
favorite slide.
I'm the only one that likes it,
but bear with me a little bit.
So I also have to apologize.
I have managed to
develop something
in my foot that might
be plantar fasciitis.
So I may sit up and down a
little bit throughout this
if my foot starts killing me.
So bear with me a
little bit here.
But we're going
to talk about-- it
looks like most of the people in
this room are IT professionals.
I've already asked
that question.
How do you actually, then,
respond to this, right?
So I focused a lot on
the business challenges,
what the business leaders
need to be thinking about.
But as IT leaders, we
have an enormous role
to play in all of this.
We have to modernize the
way we think about IT,
the way we think about
partnering with our business
partners.
So everybody is very familiar
with this concept on the left.
Anyone who's been in IT
for any period of time
understands the traditional
flow of projects.
How do you run an IT project?
Whether it's a waterfall
project or an agile project
is sort of immaterial
in this conversation.
It still starts with
a solution idea.
You have a project.
You get leadership approval
to go do that project.
You probably do a
proof of concept.
Let's prove the technology,
make sure it works.
Let's roll out a point solution,
even an IoT point solution,
that could reap real benefits
once we put it into production.
You can get benefits this way.
You can get outcomes
from those projects,
but which you can't
get is transformation.
What you can't get is
real business change.
So you've got to think about
how to widen the aperture,
let more ideas
through the process,
get more connected programs
and projects rolling.
Forget leadership approval.
Get stakeholder consensus.
Understand all the people
that touch your process,
whether it's your suppliers
and your customers
and your manufacturers
and the people
working on the shop floor.
Get them involved in designing
what this new business
model looks like and what
the technology looks like.
And do proofs of value.
We don't need to
prove the technology.
Anybody who's doing POCs at this
point to prove the technology
is missing the point.
Technology works, I promise.
What we need to see is does
it actually solve the business
problem that you're
trying to solve?
And you can't find
that out in a lab,
and you can't find that out
with just doing a data model.
You have to put it in production
in a pilot environment.
Do it quickly, see your
results, get them back.
And then you're able to have
this truly connected value
chain where you're understanding
that, as a manufacturer,
the decisions that I'm making
on the customer experience side
are influencing everything
all the way back to my supply
chain.
And all of that has to
have a digital thread.
All of that has to have
digital connectivity that
brings all of that together.
So we need to be thinking
about how to modernize IT.
And then, finally--
actually, not finally.
Sorry.
I have two more.
My third point.
There is really nothing
that consultants like more
than numbers, except roadmaps.
We really, really,
really like roadmaps.
So talking a little bit
about what a roadmap looks
like for IoT, for
digital and IoT.
It is a little bit different.
There are different
principles behind it,
but it's the same
general concept.
How you prioritize and how
you sequence your initiatives
probably has a greater impact
on your success or failure
than almost anything else.
And the reason is
what you're going
to look to do is manage these
projects, almost like a stock
portfolio.
You're looking to get
individual returns,
but it's actually more important
that you get the total return.
So if you're looking
at five different point
solutions at different
places within your factory--
one is an asset
management solution
that sits on one of
your cutting machines
if you're a metals manufacturer.
Another one is automation
that helps you make sure
that you've got better quality.
You've got video analytics
to measure worker safety.
Those are great
individual use cases.
When you connect those
together and sequence them
in the right way, you're
actually incrementally learning
from the data that you're
getting from the first,
and you're taking those
returns that you're getting,
those cost savings
you're getting,
and you're reinvesting
it in the transformation.
So how you sequence
these roadmaps
is absolutely critical,
because the goal is not
to get projects done.
The goal is to realize
value, to get to the point
where you've got
top line growth--
all those things
at the top, where
we talk about new channels, new
markets, new business models,
new ways of getting
money in the door.
And all those things
at the bottom--
increased operational
effectiveness,
reduce costs, all of
those bottom line savings.
So if you focus on the value
realization and sequence
and prioritize in
the right way, you
will see the value coming
out of these programs.
And then, finally, you
got to have an ecosystem.
Ecosystems are not new.
This is a age-old concept.
We all exist in an ecosystem.
But there are, in my
opinion, some differences,
some new things about
a digital ecosystem.
So I'm an easy example
of Hitachi and Google.
We are two huge companies.
Hitachi is number 71 on
the global 2000 list.
Google, Alphabet, is number 65.
These are massive companies.
They're top 100 biggest
companies in the world,
and we're used to
controlling our own destiny.
This is what we've done
for the bulk of our career,
especially on the Hitachi
side, as a manufacturer,
traditional business.
What we're seeing is
we can't be the center
of our own universe anymore.
We can't expect
all of our partners
and all of our customers
to orbit around us.
Instead, we've got to pick
the customers at the center.
This is not new, but it is
critically more important
than ever before.
Customer centricity
is core to digital.
Put your customers at the
middle of that ecosystem.
Enable that ecosystem
with technology,
whether it's analytics
or cloud or IT, IoT, all
of these components.
And figure out how you then
connect your entire ecosystem
together.
It's no longer just supplier,
partner, customer, company.
That used to be the ecosystem.
Now it is, how do you interact
with your governments,
with your communities, with
all of the world around you?
Because all of that
is required to make
yourself successful in digital.
So we're really excited about
our partnership with Google,
but we also know, and I'm sure
my Google colleagues would
agree with me, even our two huge
companies can't do this alone.
We have to have other partners
in the mix, other building
blocks.
All these things come
together to build
these digital solutions that
help drive transformation.
So with that, I am
going to turn it over
to the guy who's
smarter than I am who's
going to talk about the
technical building blocks,
how you bring these
things together.
Unfortunately, you're
not done with me yet.
I'll be coming back up
on the stage when Rob
is done, if he ever finishes.
We'll see how that goes.
When Rob is done,
and we're going
to talk about case studies,
real-world examples,
the stuff you guys actually care
about-- what other companies
are doing in this space.
So I'll be back.
We'll talk in a bit.
Thanks, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
ROBERT LIVELY: Hello, everyone.
How are we doing this afternoon?
OK, I'm done.
So, I'm really
excited to talk to you
guys about how we use
building blocks and solutions
within IoT, and industrial
IoT in particular,
to solve business
problems for our clients.
Now, something I think is
important to differentiate
as we start this is consumer
IoT versus industrial IoT.
They do share something
very important in common,
and that is we are trying
to acquire data, bring
it someplace that we can do
something interesting with it.
However, in industrial IoT,
we see divergences in criteria
that we need to
satisfy that don't
exist within consumer IoT.
Consumer IoT would be best
represented by something
like the Nest thermostat
that's on your wall.
It's sending, essentially,
the same data up to the cloud
all the time from every one
of those Nest thermostats.
And it's using the
same kind of protocols,
and it's doing this directly.
There is nothing
that mediates it.
It is directly connected
to the internet and sharing
information on the cloud.
In industrial internet, if we
look at security as an example,
we don't connect these devices
directly to the internet.
Even if they could,
it would be unwise,
because there's not a lot
of security on that existing
operational technology
infrastructure.
So we mediate it by putting
gateways in the middle.
And in that case, the security
requirement becomes elevated.
Where we had security
on the consumer side,
in the industrial side, we
need hardware routes of trust
so that these devices can
attest to the security
of their operating
system and the firmware.
On the scalability
side, on consumer IoT,
maybe you talk about millions
of devices connected up
and sending information,
all these Nest thermostats.
On the industrial
side, we have to talk
to thousands of
devices and thousands
of different types of devices.
So we need to be able to
mediate that conversation
and have all sorts
of gateways that
are doing different
things at different times
with different purposes.
So in order to
manage that, we need
to be able to do
things that allow
for a variety of
connectivity types
in a variety of different
devices that we need talk to.
Because we'll talk
to sensors that
may provide
temperature information
using analog signals,
or we'll talk
to SCADA systems that have their
proprietary protocols or energy
sub-meters that speak Modbus,
but a particular dialect.
So we need to be able
to adapt to that.
But there are also
other things that
come up where they aren't
a part of consumer IoT.
We need to manage
performance, so we
have to be worried about
latency versus throughput
in the data that comes through.
I need to worry about do I
need guaranteed data delivery,
or I'm OK with loss tolerance.
And it's based on use cases.
So those kind of capabilities
don't necessarily
arise when we're talking about
consumer IoT applications.
But fundamentally, the
most important thing
is at the bottom.
Its solution enablement.
With industrial IoT, we're
trying to go and solve
problems for our customers.
So the industrial
IoT application
needs to support the development
of flexible solutions
and modular deployment so we
can go and build something
interesting on top of it.
So the challenge
here, though, is
Ellen talked about an ecosystem
of contributors, partners.
And we all live
in this ecosystem
and need services and components
from the different partners
that play in this.
But the ecosystem
also needs to support
the easy participation
of different vendors
in this environment.
Because plants and
manufacturing environments
are not greenfield.
When we go to deploy
IoT, we have, certainly,
core IoT services that
are new or providing
certain fundamental
capabilities to enable
us to bring on new devices
on the edge and in the fog.
But we also find
that IoT touches
a wide range of
enterprise architecture
that provides some of these
fundamental capabilities we
were talking about
on the prior slide.
All that functional
requirement become
building block capabilities that
need to exist in order for us
to deploy solutions.
So if I'm looking
at this, I can say,
sure, there's already
security in place,
mechanisms to provide secure
connectivity of devices
onto the network.
IoT needs this, but when
we go to a deployment,
we need to see what
already exists there
and if we need to amplify
or enhance that capability
or if we need to stand it
up because it doesn't exist.
So we need building blocks that
can do those different kinds
of capabilities for us.
And on the data side,
maybe the client
already has existing
streaming infrastructure.
We need to integrate with that.
We need to get it to provide
a common interface that we
are expecting it to provide
so that we can surface data
up and do something
interesting with it.
This is where a strategic
partner like Google
comes into play.
Google provides building
blocks that align
to each of these
functional capabilities
are important for
industrial IoT.
And what's more, they
provide a variety
of building blocks in
these different areas.
So that as the need arises, I
can find the right tool set,
the right building
block to put in place
that enhances the existing
infrastructure that already
exists in that environment.
Or I can stand up a
full-fledged environment,
full-fledged capability
when that capability doesn't
exist where I go to deploy.
And Google also is consistently
innovating and creating
new solutions.
So they're building new
capabilities, new solution
building blocks that I
can leverage and think
about new kinds of creativity,
new kinds of solutions
that didn't exist before.
So this modular approach
using building blocks
allows us to reduce the time it
takes to get to business value.
So there was a
great presentation
by a gentleman Sam
Ghods at Box, where
he said a platform abstracts
away a messy problem
so you can build on top of it.
And that's what the
building blocks are doing.
They're creating a consistent
set of functionality
and a consistent way
the data is provided
and made available
through the infrastructure
so that we can focus on
building the solutions that
take advantage of that.
Again, Google is
innovating and providing
tools, such as Anthos that
they discussed the other day.
In there, Thomas Kurian
talked about Anthos
being a single platform
where you need it.
Because we want to
reduce risk, and we
want to reduce the strain on
the solution developers so
they can develop against
a common platform.
And this is reducing our
friction to implementation.
So when we talk about
solutions, though, we
start talking about recipes,
and recipes have ingredients.
In the solution,
the specific code
that runs on these building
blocks is an ingredient.
The way we configure
those building blocks
is an ingredient.
And these ingredients
are technically
decoupled from those specific
building block [INAUDIBLE]
and are reusable.
The building blocks-- if we
went with the recipe metaphor--
are things like your oven,
your stove, your pots and pans,
the things that help you
to accomplish what you need
to, to make the recipe work.
So let's take a very
specific example
to make this a
little more concrete.
So if we're doing
predictive maintenance
on weld robots in an automotive
manufacturing environment,
I need to be able to handle
a couple of different things
that need to deploy across
this entire infrastructure that
allows me to go do
predictive maintenance.
So what does that look like?
First ingredient, I
need the right data.
So I can define what data
points need to be pulled out
of the environment.
And that becomes one of the
ingredients for my recipe.
That helps me to define
what sensors I need,
what kind of capabilities
need to be deployed
within that gateway device.
Then, I can start talking
about the modules that
might need to exist in that
gateway that can talk to all
of these components that
are providing me data
and what modules might need to
be there to transform the data.
I can talk about the AI machine
learning ingredient that
needs to sit up in the cloud
that helps me to convert all
of this data, along with data
from the maintenance systems,
into a predictive
maintenance model
that I can then use to
evaluate whether or not
something is about to go wrong
with that particular machine.
So all of these
ingredients, then,
can be specified within
our solution recipe.
And that's how we take
advantage of that building block
infrastructure.
So we are layering these
things and abstracting
the baseline
infrastructure that exists
in sensors and equipment,
the building blocks that
take advantage of acquiring
that data and moving it around,
and then the solutions
that sit on top of that
and expect a common platform
and a common set of behaviors
so that we can take a predictive
maintenance solution that we
already solved and move
it somewhere else, even
if the infrastructure
is different
and the set of components
and building blocks
that we deploy
there are different.
So I'm going to dive one
section deeper and look
at what this would
look like on the edge
and give specific examples.
So on the edge,
the building blocks
are things like a common
runtime environment,
using containers, being able to
use a common message bus that
allows different containers
and modules that are running
on the edge to talk
with one another
in a consistent, uniform
specified fashion.
It's the way we connect
backup to our control plane
so we can specify how
these edge devices are
managed through edge lifecycle
management capabilities.
What's the recipe?
The recipe is the
way I configure
one of these connector modules
to talk to the device it needs
to speak to.
So I have a connector
module that's
talking to that
temperature sensor.
So it needs to know how
to read analog signals off
of an RS485 port, convert
that into data that I can use.
Or it's a Modbus module
that speaks to a sub-meter,
and I send parameters to
that Modbus module that say,
these are the
registers you read,
and that's what represents
voltage or current.
So the ingredient is the
configuration of this module.
Another ingredient would be if
I have that model I developed
that says when this
device is about to fail,
I run that in this analytic
module in the middle.
And that's converting
these data points
into real information
that's useful on the floor
in the factory and can be
connected up to other systems,
like their maintenance
system or an in-line system,
to notify them of problems.
So this brings me
back to Ellen's slide.
And this is important
because if you
take a look at that
first piece, it
says we're going to
tackle bit-sized chunks.
If you modularize
this approach, you
can identify what components you
need within your infrastructure
to enable you to go solve that
particular business problem,
and those are the
chunks you bite off.
In your solution recipe,
you have the ingredients.
You know the code.
You know the
configurations that need
to be there that solve that
particular business problem.
But that's all you're chewing
at that point in time.
So you're associating
development costs
and infrastructure costs
directly with the business
value that you're creating.
It also helps you to identify
the value of some of the bigger
pieces within the
infrastructure, all
of these investments
in data warehousing.
Those are big things
that costs a lot of money
and take a lot of
time to set up.
So being able to say that
I have a whole portfolio
of different use cases
I'm going to go support
and being able to
associate that back
to that investment
in the data warehouse
helps you to justify that as
a larger scale deployment.
And finally, we're focusing
on the business need.
This is all focused
on the solutions.
on the things
that we're trying to generate in
terms of value for our clients,
and not on the specific
technology that's
underneath it.
On one of the previous
slides, I said
industrial IoT is the
operating system for solutions.
If I'm running and
working in Excel,
I don't necessarily care
if it's running on a Mac
or if it's running
on a Windows machine.
It's Excel that
I'm interested in
and the work that I'm
able to do inside of it.
Industrial IoT
infrastructure needs
to provide the right
level of capabilities
and then disappear
into the background
so that we can allow solutions
to go give the benefit
to the client that they need.
So this is how we
deliver solutions in IoT
using building
blocks and solutions.
[APPLAUSE]
So I'm going to invite
Ellen back up on stage,
and we're going to talk
about some case studies
and show you where we've
done this type of engagement.
NARRATOR: In the IoT
era, digital disruption
and born digital competitors
transcend business and society,
catalysts of unrelenting change.
Hitachi and Google
Cloud have joined forces
to accelerate your digital
transformation journey.
Proven innovative solutions.
Business outcomes at scale
on a secure platform.
Game-changing business
strategies with agility
to ignite growth.
Success starts with
collaborative creation
and commitment to a
data-first culture.
DR. NIGEL TOMKINS: Meat
& Livestock's mission
is to drive productivity,
profitability,
and sustainability for the red
meat industry across Australia.
NARRATOR: Hitachi solves
business challenges
with digital IoT solutions
built on Google Cloud.
Through this strategic
global alliance,
organizations are taking
businesses to the next level
with data insights to
drive decision making.
DR. DEAN GUTZKE: The key to data
now is all about objectivity,
and MLA invests in
sensors, technologies,
that allows us to collect
more and more information.
The value that we've got
from working with Hitachi
has been incredible.
DR. NIGEL TOMKINS: We manage
not only on-farm data,
but how we make best use of it.
Every transaction that
that animal goes through,
we need to be able
to map and track.
DR. DEAN GUTZKE: We
are now setting up
weather stations where we can
measure not only the rain.
We're measuring the
temperature, the wind.
We are now starting to
measure the soil temperature
so we understand when the
best growth is for us.
It's very important we get all
that livestock data together
to be able to make
good decisions on where
we're heading.
NARRATOR: Together,
Hitachi and Google Cloud
are helping Meat & Livestock
Australia navigate this IoT
journey.
Real-time data is collected
from disparate sensors, systems,
and aerial imagery, and
a massive data repository
synthesized and hosted
on Google Cloud drives
accelerated decision making
operational efficiency.
A dashboard view
provides transparency
across the supply chain to
improve decision making.
Google Cloud Compute
and Storage capabilities
deliver reliability
and scalability.
HUGH BANKS: The future
is pretty exciting.
The technology we're seeing
today is only the start of it.
We're going to see a lot bigger
and better ideas coming forward
in the next few years.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
ELLEN DOWD: All
right, so we're going
to talk about this for
just a couple of minutes
and then move on to a
few more case studies.
I know this isn't
technically manufacturing.
You could make the argument
that we're manufacturing meat,
but I don't like to
think of it that way.
I'm a vegetarian.
So instead, we're
just going to look
at this from a pure
social innovation story.
I love this case
study specifically
because it brings
that concept of why
you need an ecosystem to life.
So, Meat & Livestock Australia
is a public/private partnership
with the meat producing
companies in Australia
and the farmers who are
actually responsible for taking
care of these cows.
So it is bringing together
their own ecosystem
with our ecosystem.
So Hitachi came in and did
the systems integration,
provided some of the sensors.
Some of them we got third party.
We had to partner
with another company
to create the drones to
be able to go out and take
aerial photos of the
cattle and the livestock.
We were able to bring together
that with the power of Google
to create a really
compelling solution that
required about 17 different
entities from the customer side
as well as the service
provider side to be successful.
So it's a really
great story that
has been able to
show true improvement
for this industry in Australia.
So I really like
telling this story.
ROBERT LIVELY:
We're manufacturing
very healthy live animals.
ELLEN DOWD: Yes, that's right.
When I watch that
video, I try to imagine
that we're just taking the
cows to a different pasture.
So that's where my head goes.
All right, so I'm
going to let Rob talk
about this one in detail.
But I will say, one of
the things that I think
is super interesting
about this customer--
and Rob's going to go into
some of the details around what
we're actually doing
for them-- but they're
a global 1000
automotive manufacturing
company that knows auto
manufacturing is probably
not their future.
They look to the
future, and they
know that they need to
be a mobility company.
They need to be thinking
about, how are we
going to move people around?
How are people going to go
from point A to point B?
It may not be in a car that
they own in the future.
So how do we build towards that?
But they also know that
as volumes go down,
as fewer people are buying
cars, as they're producing fewer
cars, they also have to optimize
their manufacturing operations
in the meantime to be able
to squeeze as much operating
efficiency as they
possibly can in order
to be able to stay
competitive in the market.
ROBERT LIVELY: So
when we first went
to work with this
particular manufacturer,
they had identified
11 different use cases
that they wanted to tackle
within their industrial IoT
infrastructure.
The challenge was
that they ranged
from predictive maintenance and
predictive quality all the way
through to energy management
and worker safety.
And as we dissected
the requirements
of these different use
cases, what we identified
is that these were asking
very different kinds
of functionality to exist
within that industrial IoT
infrastructure.
In some places, we needed
to process view imaging
real time right at the edge.
In other times, we
needed to be able to do
very low latency
transfer of information
all the way from the
manufacturing floor
through to the cloud,
combine it with other data,
and send responses back so
that they can make decisions
in real time, or near real time,
about the way in which they
operated the plant.
So these building
blocks became really
critical to be able
to say, this is
how we're going to go and
put components in place that
support this.
And then the modularity
of the solutions
allowed us to define what
kind of ingredients--
code and configuration-- needed
to exist at different points
within that infrastructure.
And so we were able to take
the same fundamental platform
and ask it to do very,
very different things
and still get the
same responsiveness
and control out of
it that we need.
ELLEN DOWD: All right.
And again, I'm going to let Rob
talk about some of the details
here.
But this customer, I think,
is particularly interesting,
because there is
probably nothing
more old school traditional
when it comes to manufacturing
as steel manufacturing.
Steel manufacturing
is one of the first,
literally one of the first,
manufacturing operations
that ever existed
anywhere in the world.
And it hasn't really modernized
all that much over that time.
So we're working with
a US steel manufacturer
who is looking at solving--
they're actually not
envisioning this grand new world
of the future.
They have massive
operational challenges
that they need to address,
and they believe that,
by looking at IoT, by looking
at better usage of their data,
they can drive real results.
So they had any
number of problems
around unplanned downtime
of their manufacturing line.
A bunch of stuff
was done manually
and, therefore, not optimized.
They had mislabeled products
coming off the line.
They had any number
of challenges there.
So we went in and
helped them, again,
prioritize those use cases
and decide what to go after.
ROBERT LIVELY: And the
challenge here, again,
was that when we looked at
these use cases, the problems
that they were finding,
that it required
a vast array of different
kinds of sensors
and different kind
of capabilities
that we literally
developed with partners
that didn't exist before.
So we were able to--
for example, one
of the instances
was looking at the
tension on a steel line
and whether or not
there was potential
that steel line could break.
So we actually worked with
the sensor manufacturers
to design something
specifically for that use case.
And then it starts spitting off
some of this interesting data.
We needed to be able to easily,
rapidly deploy connectivity
components out there
that would take advantage
of that new information,
standardize it, bring it
into the infrastructure so that
we could do something with it,
and solve the business case.
The other thing was that
in one particular instance,
the client felt as
though they understood
what the problem was with a
particular aspect of cutting
some steel.
And as we started to
put things in place
to observe what was going on,
we identified that that actually
wasn't the case.
It was something else
about that process that
was causing the quality issues.
And we were able
to quickly throw
in an additional
sensor, additional piece
of information, plug it into
the same infrastructure,
stream that data up,
and immediately convert
from solving one
aspect of that problem
to a different aspect
of that problem.
So, once again, those components
and the approach of modularity
helps us to respond
and adapt very quickly
and deliver a business
value for the client.
[MUSIC PLAYING]